all right joker is here it's out maybe
you've seen it hopefully you've seen it
if you haven't seen it hopefully you see
it this weekend if you're not going to
don't stay home because of the fear
mongering [ __ ] on Twitter anyhow
this is my Joker spoiler talk if you
haven't seen Joker yet you probably
shouldn't watch it as usually I'm
located come on in stay if you don't
care about spoilers but benefit of the
doubt you should leave now because you
should watch Joker but that's a spoiler
warning spoiler warnings done let's talk
about Joker and Joaquin Phoenix okay
look guess the way I say Joaquin Phoenix
is one of two ways I either roll it and
breathe the hakin Phoenix or I say
Joaquin Phoenix in which case people
here locking Phoenix which sounds like a
zombie show that's gonna go on for about
five seasons too long either way or any
case it's either an accent or I just
pronounced it incorrectly but it's not
gonna change and also this video is not
going to be a play-by-play
scene-by-scene scene for scene although
I'll probably take more time and going
through the scenes than I usually do but
you know let's talk about the spoilers
things I couldn't talk about and my
spoiler free review and I can't talk
about it now and anyhow here we go how
[ __ ] good is Joaquin Phoenix in this
movie like right when the movie starts
out it's when he's like grinning in the
mirror making the smile that the tears
going down running his makeup and he's
just like has this sad look on his face
from there to when he's talking to his
therapist and he hands the therapist
adjure I'm he doesn't just hand it to
her you can tell he's like these are my
personal thoughts they don't hand it to
you but he hands her the journal and
when she opens it up you just see you
see notes but you also see pictures of
flayed bodies it reminded me of American
psychos like that is an American Psycho
kind of moment also when American Psycho
came out did you see the spike of serial
killers in America no [ __ ] exactly
but you can tell this guy's he's not
okay he's in pain what I like about this
movie is as it goes on you start like I
said peeling away the layers like as if
he's an ogre
there's intrigue there's revelation you
just keep going you're like oh he did
have a fucked-up childhood do because at
first it feels like all right he's
dealing with some stuff but his
relationship with his mom is he's nice
to his mom almost too nice because you
know he's bathing her I don't know I
don't know the relationship that seems a
bit too close for me but maybe they
couldn't afford a caretaker and she
needed one or she might be one of those
moms it's like I don't need a caretaker
but I want him as my caretaker which is
real
manipulative which it does show that she
is manipulative that's what I took it as
so that's one of the things that shows
that gonna jump tracks for a second we
got to talk about his laughs because
it's left like he has that condition
where he could uncontrollably laughs and
YouTube was like hey suggested video
this guy who has that condition it was
uploaded like four years ago I guess no
one cared then they all care now and
YouTube cares to bring that to me
because you know Joker so I was watching
this and it's just like the movie just
dudes like laughing but he doesn't want
to live and it kind of hurts his throat
I never saw Joker's laugh as this
chronic condition that causes him pain
it's the first time I've ever seen that
I'm actually baffled no one's ever done
that before unless it was a comic book
out there that does illustrate that but
I just haven't seen it when is one of
his clown colleagues gives him a gun and
if he just shoots it through the wall he
doesn't really how to handle a gun but
he has his gun and then those those
subway [ __ ] come at him and he
shoots them and I feel like this is the
moment when people some people who
didn't like the movie shut off from the
movie they're like oh don't like it
anymore and I'll tell you exactly why if
you're one of those people stopped me if
I'm wrong on this one you saw that
moment where Joker unloaded on the
subway dip shits and you didn't squeak a
tear for those guys in fact you liked it
when he killed them cuz those guys were
dicks and it made you feel weird it's
like Joe could kill these people and I
liked it cuz [ __ ] them the [ __ ] heads is
what you felt right yeah you're supposed
to the movie set you up to feel like
that after he has his freakout moment
you can tell that's the most control
he's ever felt in his life like he's
never felt that powerful but then
there's intrigue like his mom's always
riding Thomas Wayne like oh because
we're like family Thomas wins like all
my employees are like family and you're
like oh she's kind of taking that a bit
too far and then you read the note it's
like oh god Arthur Fleck is his kid I
was like way Bruce Wayne's his
half-brother oh but turns out yeah she's
she's nuts and that was probably really
frustrating for Thomas white it's like
yeah this mentally unstable insane
stalker lady he used to work at my
company she's been stalking me for years
that probably was not comfortable for
him I understand his frustration I
understand his frustration I understand
Arthur flex pain that's one of the great
things about this movie it's like I
understand him oh good I understand him
brilliant so it turns out the Bruce
Wayne being his half-brother thing that
wasn't real
when he goes to Bruce Wayne to like puts
his fingers in his mouth and makes him
smile and Alfred comes out is like get
out like yeah if I saw some weird guy
putting his fingers and my kid's mouth
and making a smiling have kids but or
even if I was a butler I'd be like you
that's gross and you're a smoker but now
his mouth tastes like cigarettes dude I
like to see where he's in the comedy
club zazzy beast is there supporting him
mm but he's there and he's kind of
choking onstage literally and
figuratively because he can't stop
laughing but when he's taking notes
before he gets onstage before he
actually makes his move he's taking
notes and he's laughing on the offbeat
you know like the audience laughs and a
couple beats later he laughs it's like
he's not in sync with the audience I
like that that's just I like the moment
then he gets onstage you don't see how
he does and then yeah Robert DeNiro
Murray on the Murray show he's like Oh
check this guy out and we already saw it
in the trailer I do think the trailer
showed a bit more it showed a couple
scenes that I think they should have
saved for the movie but yeah just she
wasn't bombing out and Murray's talking
[ __ ] the other scene that the trailer
showed that I don't think they should
have showed was when he says can you
introduce me as Joker like that's a huge
moment for the movie should have shown
that in the trailer I will say the
relationship with Zazi beets that was
the weak part of the movie when I'm
watching I'm like okay if I have a
critique in my review which I didn't
have in my review because I'm saving it
for here because there's a reason I was
like she's the weak part of the movie or
at least that relationships the weak
part of the movie she was fine for what
she had but I was like all right this
relationship kind of feels like either
an afterthought or something in the
background it's not really grabbing me
there's a reason though because it has
its Sixth Sense moment you see these
moments of him and her and he's all
happy then at a point he's in her
apartment she's like your name's Arthur
right and what are you doing in my
apartment
can you please leave I was like oh we're
in a beautiful mind like it never
happened
oh [ __ ] which is actually great that
they used her sparingly because if there
were too many scenes where it was just
him and her and people didn't interact
with her people might have caught on
because a few movies have done that at
this point but it was sparingly enough
to where I was I was genuinely
didn't see that coming and then he
leaves implications did he kill her you
hear sirens and I don't know if it was
for the apartment that he was in he
might have actually liked this a little
like maybe he did maybe he didn't you
don't really know he does kill his mom
no he gives his mom like the RP McMurphy
gives her you know the chief to RP
McMurphy and Cuckoo's Nest just takes a
pillow that's when he was like I usually
think of my life was a tragedy it turns
out as a [ __ ] comedy and you just he
just smothers which these two cops have
been questioning him the entire movie
which I also like cuz you could tell
these guys are like this guy's totally
he did it and after his mom dies there's
no like they're like he absolutely did
it and then Arthur it somehow gets a
phone call from the talk-show the one
where De Niro was talking [ __ ] about him
in like yeah we totally want you to come
on the show and he was like cool and
then his rehearsal in his living room is
so good when he has the show on and he
has a recording and he's playing it and
he has the little drapes and the couch
and the chair and he comes out he's
trying to like alright he's trying to
get it perfect trying to emulate how a
confident person would come out on that
show and then he's like miming shooting
himself and you're like okay that's how
it's gonna go down that's when I was
like oh all right so he's gonna die so
this isn't really a joker story it's a
joker ish story about a guy who's not
really the Joker or it's a Joker story
about the Joker but hey the Joker only
lived this long and this is kind of a
realistic representation of the Joker
right there I was like alright he's
gonna die
maybe but after he kills his mom before
he goes on the Murray show he paints his
face white it's wood it's really creepy
looking like him even in the trailer was
like that's unsettling more unsettling
than the clown makeup but the guy who
his that colleague that sold him the gun
and the little dude they all come over
to his place they're like what's with
the makeup he's like my mom died
celebrating and then he stabs a big guy
with the scissors and all right this is
the scene it's probably it's one of my
favorite Joker moments in a movie like
when I say Joker mamas I mean the
moments that embody the Joker like that
is the Joker moment if he stabs the big
guy with the scissors he's covered in
blood that guy's dead the little dudes
over there freaking out and he's like
I'm dead too and then Arthur or joke or
whatever you want to call him at this
point he's like you've always been good
to me
go and the dude runs past him but the
doors locked and the latch is up there
and it's out of his reach
he just can't reach it and so you're
like did he latch that on purpose and
tell him he could go just so he can kill
him when he can't reach the latch or is
he genuinely gonna let him go you don't
know I don't know if that dude's gonna
die right now I don't know if Arthur
Fleck is gonna kill himself or not on
the Murray show I don't know I did and
that's what I love about it I love the
fact this movie put me in situations
where it's like I don't know if these
people are going to live and die by the
end of the movie and that moment right
there was such a cat-and-mouse moment
like in terms of Joker moments if you
look at how sinister the moment is how
playful the moment is and how much
anxiety the moment gives you unsure you
are about how all of its gonna go down
that is a great Joker moment I'm sure
enough he unlatches the door kisses his
dude on the head sends him on his wife
dude lifts and that's when you're like
okay he let him live which means he
knows that he's gonna kill himself on
the show so now he's embraced the make
up after the cops are told me they're
watching him dance and he just is
carrying himself with all the confidence
in the world gets into a chase with the
cops makes it to the Murray show and
that's when he's like can you introduce
me as Joker they don't want him to go on
because you know clowns are kind of
raising a ruckus right now when he comes
out you know like you see him behind the
curtain and he raises his arm and he has
a cigarette and he comes out and you
know he spins he goes over to dr. Ruth
he kisses her on the lips you know I'm
like dude this is he is the Joker the
way he carries himself he completely
cells that make up as the Joker's make
up he's a completely different person
he's embraced who he is and he also
embraces the fact that this is his last
day alive and really has nothing to lose
and if you look at the Joker that's how
he carries himself he acts he's a
walking ed nothing is keeping him in
check he's just living for today because
tomorrow he dies he's in the moment
that's how this Joker is carrying
himself which I do believe up until that
moment that it was zooming into him and
he had the cigarette and here's Murray
still talking [ __ ] about all those guys
a lot of problems I'll tell you that I
do believe he meant to off he was gonna
off himself on air then at that point
he's like I'm gonna take this guy out
with me and then he just didn't kill
himself it was a little on the nose when
he was like what do you get when you
have a loner and you ignore a loner in
this society however
he says I could get what you [ __ ]
deserve but I will say that hit that
bang the one that everyone's afraid that
people are gonna emulate that shot is so
real and it was so like it instantly
makes you feel dirty it's just a
sickening shot it's a sickening moment
he just unloads on him again goes over
to the camera and starts talking into it
also a joker moment he would totally do
that which the cops get him so you
assumed he was just there talking in the
camera cops arrest him when he's in the
cop car you look around there's just
like there's riots happening people in
clown masks starting fires tipping cars
over you know basic riot [ __ ] cops like
you see all this [ __ ] you cuz he's like
yeah isn't it beautiful or however he
phrased it like the last 20 minutes of
this movie the moment he puts on the
makeup and kills that former colleague
of his from then to the end of the movie
he is the Joker
Arthur Fleck died with his mom and then
these clowns plow into that car and get
him out and his mouth is bleeding and he
makes the Joker smile and he's kind of
embraces like I'm the Rat King I'm the
leader of all of these guys all of these
maniacs are kind of mine the Joker
attracts in the words of the great
Christian Bale Batman which I won't lie
that's the hot toy I want you know like
they're gonna come they have to come out
with a hot toy this right clean Joker
makeup I was like oh yeah I'll totally
get that but the one where he's just
kind of battered and bruised and he has
the blood smile they should make the
Wayne's do get murdered it goes past
this theater and the Wayne's are coming
out of the theater as like all you know
all the riots of clowns are going down
because the clowns have been inspired by
Arthur Fleck or Joker killing those guys
in the subway though I wouldn't say
Joker because he wasn't Joker when he
did it point is in the alley these guys
kill the Wayne's and I do feel like that
was was that a reshoot that feels like
that was tacked on like the movie had
this clean ending they were like we do
want to see the winds get killed in this
movie and this is a good opportunity to
do it it was just some other clown who
did it but I do feel like it was a
little like they had to nudge like hey
this is still a Batman movie which I
don't think they should lead this into
the Batman universe I like it as its own
standalone movie rumor is walking Venus
was like I don't want to do a franchise
so he's probably not gonna do it dudes
an artist I respect that but you know
they were like this is
good okay we're gonna we're gonna at
least leave the option open like right
now they're probably thinking how can we
tie this in to it and maybe we'll we'll
try to convince him later yeah we'll see
what happens it is what it is the Wayans
Gate kill but then he's in the mental
hospital and he's talking to this other
therapist this person who's interviewing
him and he he laughs and she goes what
what is it and he goes I just thought of
something funny or something like that
or I thought of a joke and he thinks of
Bruce Wayne standing over his dead
parents she goes what is it he goes you
wouldn't get it there's one thing about
people especially that I've noticed on
social media it's like when they have a
thought they really feel like they have
to convince you of it or if they find
something funny they have to illustrate
to you why they think it's funny it's in
people's nature to try to convince you
that you know to validate their own mind
but he just doesn't give a [ __ ] he's
like you wouldn't get it when he's
walking out you see he's leaving bloody
footprints which one symbolism but -
yeah he killed her - then he reaches the
end of the hallway you just see like
doctors chasing him and he's just like
running and he's laughing and it's a
game to him also another Joker moment
after killing somebody just like all
right now we have a Tom and Jerry moment
Tom and Jerry moment with the
authorities this movie has some great
Joker moments in it and in the end I
thought this was a great movie I've done
nothing but think about it after I saw
it and it's it's kind of messed up it
makes you feel gross because you do
sympathize with the guy you recognize
what he does is wrong at no point is the
movie like it's cool to be like him but
you don't want to be like him you don't
want his life when he kills people it's
very raw and you don't want any part of
that like it nope no the movie makes you
question your own moral fiber and I just
love it when movies are messed up like
that enough to make you question
yourself on a serious note I've seen a
lot of chatter online like you know a
lot of I'll say articles blogs I'll call
them blogs because it's not really
journalism there's been a lot of talk
about maybe the Joker movie might
inspire a mass shooting I have a lot of
thoughts about that long story short
Joker might inspire mass shootings that
that isn't the conversation it shouldn't
be anyway that's just the conversation
we've had since the 90s does violent
entertainment inspire violence it's
redundant repair
and lazy but also Joker looks like it
has a lot of other conversations it
wants to have and it wants to start
about society a lot of themes that
aren't getting talked about some themes
in this movie that's his movies begging
to have talked about is mental health
take it seriously don't cut funding to
it maybe we should recognize the warning
signs and the cries for help if
someone's an oddball though they're
being a little weird maybe we shouldn't
just you know do the easy thing which is
talk [ __ ] don't be like the talk show
host Marie in this movie it's so easy to
do that especially with the internet
with that disconnect it's like you don't
see them as people so easy just get on
your keyboard and talk [ __ ] but there
are people who deal with it cutting
people down it's just a sign of a weak
mind not that I've never done that but
you know the goal is to better yourself
also the dangers of social divide like
this movie addresses social divide
that's huge why are we not talking about
any of this anyhow in the end Joker I
loved it it's haunting it's
uncomfortable it's amazing it's well
acted a lot of things I wanted in this
Joker movie I got in this Joker movie
and it's like I've seen some complaints
from people who say this movie is
dangerous and I just what did you think
a Joker movie was gonna be want to be
like oh this is your first Joker
experience congratulations cuz of course
it was going to be like this here's a
thing that'll [ __ ] your brain everybody
who has loved the Joker since before
this movie came out we all knew exactly
who the Joker was we knew he was this
kind of [ __ ] this kind of maniac it's
nothing new I'm just glad a filmmaker
todd phillips saw it and gave us
something accurate for the joker
something joker accurate so thank you
Todd Phillips in a minute I will ask you
what you thought about Joker but first
I'm so sure I don't want to think the
sponsor of this video the sponsor of
this video is Ray Khan you might have
seen these wireless Bluetooth headphones
making their way around YouTube whether
it's sponsorships people doing videos on
them it's quite a few celebrities like
for icons like Snoop likes Roy Cohn so
he's the one I'm name-dropping here so
they sent me a pair tried them out and
yes they're pretty sweet they're stylish
little headphones no wires whatsoever
which my other pair of bluetooth
headphones had the wire so either put it
behind you and it gets caught on your
collar and falls out of your ear or you
put the wire in front of you and it just
dangles there like a shoelace knot these
right cons though these are completely
wireless sleek stylish earbuds
they also come in a variety of fit
options I love the fact that you can
choose your size because I earbuds
always fall out of my ears these ones
have yet to fall out of my ears and
that's while I'm working out which I'm
not going to show you footage of because
it's kind of embarrassing maybe one day
though today you get me bobbing my head
and testing to see if they fall out of
my didn't know they didn't fall out of
my ears awesome and as you may have
heard by now their latest model is their
best one yet with six hours of playtime
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass and
a more compact design that gives you a
nice noise isolating fit and they come
in a variety of colors and rake on
earbuds start at about half the price of
most other premium earbuds on the market
that's what I do here I save you some
money you want to save more money fine
you drive a hard bargain I'll save you
another 15% go to rake on Comm slash
Jones or click the link below to save
yourself another 15% like how I did
that's how I do sponsorship so click the
link pick yourself up a parent thank you
again to rake on for sponsoring this
video appreciate it alright so Joker
have you seen it what did you think
about it I can say that now whatever you
thought about Joker comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]